[Music]
what we're seeing today
is dramatic evidence of what happens
when you fail to talk honestly about
your history
and it hearkens to the mid-19th century
during the civil war so lincoln becomes
important to reflect on the issues of
division that we're seeing today
abraham lincoln has outwitted just about
as many historians as politicians of his
own day unless you understand what is
going on around what he is saying you
can never really understand abraham
lincoln
lincoln did not start his presidency to
be the great emancipator it's not a
phrase lincoln asked to be applied to
himself and we can do better
frederick douglass is every bit the
equal of the president of the united
states he's constantly in lincoln's ear
pushing him on black humanity
as the voices that have access to link
and change lincoln himself changes in
response
[Music]
lincoln's number one agenda is
unification it is not the abolition of
slavery
[Music]
lincoln was forced to reckon with
slavery due to black people themselves
he came to think that out of this would
come something truly monumental
lincoln is talking about doing something
pretty radical here something really
important inside of him was opening up
he was trying to navigate the currents
of really irreconcilable ideas
[Music]
you